hey kitchen now Oh cake
what's up something's not right about
that guy why just because he keeps
threatening they'd kill me in the middle
of a police precinct grow up because I'm
physically attracted to him
damn that's bad I'm only attracted to
creeps the vulture the ShamWow guy when
I was a kid had a major crush on the
evil gremlin stripe
are you crazy yeah well I'm not gonna
bone gizmo what careful with you Mentos
it's gonna be fine
dere's cement Oh what's up what's up
with you I need you to sign this report
okay I'll sign your report
what the hell
careful being still wet maybe this'll
help okay they got to knock that off
loosen up Sarge somewhere love baby
it's March man shut up you punching
holes yeah that's way too much paper not
for me
can't even get a cup of coffee
well I'm off to find some yellow paper
so I can do this all over again
all right yes that's it what's going on
with you two
Oh you notice it yeah I noticed it
everyone's noticed it a convicted
pervert asked me if you guys could cool
it I don't know what to tell you
some between us Sarge something dark and
urgent
mm-hmm I could have done that yeah I
know you could have but you didn't I did
I mean lots of other polls guys a whole
street full of them so Adrian I'm gonna
stop messing around and do this thing
never what you know what I just realized
I forgot something at home I'm just
gonna that was weird
you okay yes yes we talked what do you
want the mint oh listen Sarge gave me
some really great advice
so Rosa Diaz will you marry me what this
is what you told me to do I barely said
anything you cut me off way too early
Sarge stay out of this gladly no I will
not marry you how about we just get a
drink first yeah yeah that sounds nice
oh that's actually sweet no check it out
losers
guess who got their dealer nice how'd it
go down I chase him through a subway
tunnel back up through a storm drain
Adrian I got engaged and then we busted
him with half a kilo of coke in his sock
wait what'd you just say it was in his
sock these dummies they never think
we're gonna check their socks no before
that weirdo the getting engaged part oh
yeah we got engaged engaged engaged yeah
as in to be wet yeah seriously yeah
amazing we want teeth tell us Africa I
don't want to toot my own horn or
anything but it was super romantic
you follow I'll cut him off the alley
okay wait you want to get married yep
you wanted me to tell you that he loves
you is that it did he say anything else
may the Lord be with you
Adrienne whoo
scared me I thought you left I did I was
burning my fingerprints off in a gas
station bathroom and I thought about
what Jake said I couldn't leave without
seeing one last time I want to look your
whole body clean like a kitty cat yeah
I'm gonna give you two a little space
[Music]
hey Figgis my fiancee Adrian pimento
said when I caught you I should read you
this letter I want to lick the skin off
your body baby
oh that sights for me I want to rip the
skin off your body Jimmy yes we will oh
yeah this is awkward
I'm sure they'll stop soon let's go I
left my phone in the briefing room it's
been 20 minutes do you think they're
still there not doing anything kissing
just turned to talk it's like why did it
work here listen up we have an
announcement to make
when I was in that news BEC prison
choking on my own blood because my face
was being beaten in I realized life is
funny that's what you realized and it's
short we're picking up where we left off
when Adrian went into hiding we're
getting married tomorrow Oh tomorrow
that's real quick Thank You sergeant and
we want it to be beautiful and lush and
romantic just like a Nancy Meyers movie
she's our favorite director well I love
you've got mail that's Nora Ephron you
idiot I know all right we have an
announcement to make
we're not getting married oh good shove
those ahhs up your butts yeah or I'll
come out there and I'll do it for you
what an interesting event I just feel
like we were rushing things we love each
other but we haven't even really spent
that much time together we've never even
been on a real date so I'm gonna start
there shut up thank you for the presents
we're keeping them hey hey you forgot
your lunch at home Adrian course I
French kissed every slice of meat in
that sandwich pimento welcome back how
is our Jen Tina it's kind of boring
actually although one funny thing did
happen to me
feels like you and I have a different
idea about what a funny thing is right
anyway I should buggy right say goodbye
to mommy mm-hmm hang on were you creeps
watching that the whole time just
kidding I know you were it's like an
eclipse you should always look at it
with both eyes wide open full-on you're
welcome I love you babe
love me too yeah I see so nice having
pimento back
I mean you shouldn't eat that sandwich
something's wrong he's acting weird Hey
so he's doing okay not really
we don't side that restaurant for two
hours and he never came out cantaloupe
I'm good ami also good I'll so good I
spent the whole night riding my bike
just thinking and writing writing and
thinking also I drink some water from a
stream and what did you figure out I'm
gonna dump his ass you should be here
any minute
how are you doing at work that's great
there you are babe I've been looking for
you all night you didn't come home
because I knew if I did I would stab you
in the face Oh
Terry we have the thing in the other
room phone yeah meeting work Prynne
lunch yep so is this a sexy step in the
face or an angry stab in the face don't
play dumb with me I know about your
mistress I know about La palapa I know
about the flood babe wait oh I've been
waiting I waited all night to do this
we're done it's over what I don't have a
mistress that woman's name is Senor
erase she's my Spanish teacher oh please
no I'm serious the only reason we were
even at La palapa so I can practice
ordering in Spanish and by the way el
restaurante de NOS dijo que compare tear
up flan I did estoy aprendiendo español
para impression rr2 padre oh my god oh
my god Adrian I'm so sorry you must be
so mad at me what of course I'm not mad
at you are you kidding jealousy is like
the hottest emotion let's do this okay
let's do it
thank you for understanding yeah oh look
oh boy here's your blood back mmm well
in that case I guess you should have
your blood back too
what how did you get this you know I
might want a couple minutes up here
alone just to kind of process this you
know of course so how'd it go
actually went surprisingly well honestly
the best
you